alright internet I want to talk about
the constant outrage machine we are all
outraged constantly at everything we all
open up our Twitter immediately start
figuring out what we can be pissed at
who we can yell at who's offending us
and I've just about had enough of it uh
I was watching the State of the Union
last week and I was tweeting the whole
thing and I was ripping everybody apart
I was attacking obama i was attacking
the Republicans the Democrats I was
making fun of the overly Botox faces
members of the Senate I was attacking
the way they dressed just across the
board everything and then Michelle
Malkin who is a right winger on Fox News
all time she runs a thing called twitchy
and they wrote a whole article about me
basically saying that I was making fun
of gay people and I was making fun of
women blah blah blah and then they said
the only person that I didn't attack was
the president which of course wasn't
true because I talked about how bad our
foreign policies been how he's playing
it both ways on net neutrality and it
was just making me think that this
constant outrage that everyone is
monitoring the internet to figure out
who you can be pissed that or upset by
then you know King Abdullah from Saudi
Arabia died last week and I tweeted
something to the effect of you know only
in the Middle East with a guy who's for
beheadings and killing gays and that
won't let women Drive would be
considered a moderate well then I
started getting people hating me on that
that I hate women cuz I don't really
understand how they treat women better
that apparently by not letting women
drive that means just how much they love
women and then I got tons of people you
know tell me to go [ __ ] myself [ __ ] you
know a lot a lot of really brilliant
wonderful stuff anyway it's just putting
more of a focus on saying that I think
we're all exhausted because I hear this
for my friends all the time and when we
do the show from the guests that we're
talking to that people are exhausted of
the outrage there used to be a time when
you would be outraged privately and you
know you didn't have to share every
thought with everything I know as
someone that's speaking and that does
the online thing I guess that's a little
ironic but I think we could all tone it
down a little bit and understand that
part of freedom of speech and freedom of
expression which is so important right
now with everything going on in Paris
with Charlie Hebdo and all that that we
could all just allow people to talk
allow people to print what they want to
print draw a [ __ ] they want to draw and
make jokes about what they want to joke
about and that the world is not going to
come
to it and then you don't have to be
outraged all day long and you know what
folks everything's going to be a okay